اهلا بكم اربعه احداث في 4 ساعه فقط في
مصر في البدايه تحذير من وزاره الخارجيه
الالمانيه للرعايا الالمان بتوق الحذر عند
السفر الى مصر نظرا لاحتمال وقوع عمليات
ارهابيه في مناطق السياحيه تزامن التحذير
الالماني مع اعلان الكنائس المصريه وقف
انشطتها ورحلاتها الخارجيه في ضوء تعليمات
شفويه من وزاره الداخليه بعد ذلك بساعات
قتل خمسه من افراد الشرطه في هجوم على
كمين امني متحرك في ابوصير بمحافظه الجيزه
في منطقه سياحيه اعقب ذلك تسلل شخص م مسلح
بسكين الى شاطئ فندق بالغردقه فقتل
سائحتين
المانيتول معها السلطات المصريه تقرير
خليل بن
الدين لم يكد تحذير الخارجيه الالمانيه
بتوخي الحذر عند السفر الى مصر لاحتمال
وقوع عمليه ارهابيه واختطاف يصل الى ر اها
حتى جاءت الاخبار عاجله من الغردقه تنبئ
بمقتل سائحتين
المانيتول بالسكين نفذه وفق السلطات
الامنيه المصريه شخص تسلل من شاطئ احد
الفنادق السياحيه سباحه من خلال شاطئ عام
مجاور وتمكن من الوصول لمكان تنفيذ
الجريمه هجوم اخر راح ضحيته خمسه من افراد
الامن المصري كانت محافظه الجيزه مسرحا له
تظهر و الهجوم مجموعه من المسلحين اطلقوا
النار من سلاح الي على سياره شرطه كانت
تقوم بدوريه امنيه كانت السلطات المصريه
تستشعر تهديدات امنيه وشيكه فلقد اوعزت
للكنائس المصريه شفاهه بالاكتفاء بالطقوس
والصلوات العاديه داخل الكنائس والاديره
والكف عن تنظيم اي رحلات او نشاطات ملفته
للانتباه حتى نهايه الشهر الجاري كما تم
ابلاغ الاقباط الذين كانوا في رحلات او
معسكرات الشبابيه بقطع انشطتهم والعوده
الى بيوتهم كان في ذهن السلطات الهجومات
والتفجيرات التي راح ضحيتها نحو 100 قتيل
من المسيحيين بشكل خاص في القاهره
والاسكندريه وطنطا ومحافظه المنيا يعيد
الهجوم على منطقتي الجيزه والغردقه
سياحيتين بامتياز طرح سؤال تامين هذه
المناطق التي تدر على القاهره دخلا كبيرا
ولكنه يطرح قبل ذلك سؤال تامين مصر كلها
من هجومات اصبحت متوقعه وصعبه على الاجهزه
الامنيه حتى الان تلافيها اعلنت حاله
الطوارئ في ابريل الماضي ووسعت معها
صلاحيات الشرطه في تنفيذ اعتقالات في صفف
المدنيين ادت الى تطبيق اجراءات قضائيه
مستعجله شددت اجراءات الامن حول الكنائس
ولجات السلطات الى تنفيذ عمليات امنيه
وعسكريه خاصه في سيناء غاب في الاثناء عن
السلطات المصريه ان التعزيزات الامنيه
وحدها ليست كافيه لاسترجاع السكينه والامن
والطمانينه لشعب يعاني من غياب حل لخلافات
سياسيه اما الاوضاع الاقتصاديه في البلد
فتزداد صعوبه هي ايضا تدهورت القدره
الشرائيه للمواطن وتدهورت قيمه الجنيه ولم
يبقى الكثير من السلع تتمكن العائلات
الفقيره من اقتنائها خصوصا بعد اعلان
وزاره التموين ايقاف دعم الدقيق الموجه
لبرنامج الخبز المدعم الشهر المقبل
ومناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا في الاستوديو
نيفين ملك المحاميه والنشطه الحقوقيه
المصريه ومن لندن الدكتور عمر عاشور استاذ
الدراسات الامنيه والعلوم السياسيه في
جامعه اكستر البريطانيه ومن القاهره عبر
الهاتف اللواء مجد الشاهد مساعد وزير
الداخليه المصري السابق وابدا بك في
الواقع سيده اللواء مجدي الشاهد يعني بعد
ساعات من تحذير الخارجيه الالمانيه يقع
هجومان هجوم الغردقه
وهجوم ابو سير في في الجيزه هجومان
مختلفان الاول استهدف سياحا ول الصدفه
تبين ان القتلى من الالمان والثاني استهدف
جنودا في دوريه متحركه وليست دوريه ثابته
دوريه
متحركه ما دلاله هذين
الهجومين الحقيقه بس عايز اقول انه ما فيش
ربط بالتاثير الق على القوه الاقتصاديه
وانخفاض فاضي الحاله الاقتصاديه ومحاوله
تاسيس الامور الامنيه هذا غير صحيح لان
الدول الاوروبيه حتى السعوديه اليوم تعرضت
لحادث والدول الاوروبيه تعرضت لحوادث
ارهابيه ودخل الفرد فيها والحياه
الاقتصاديه منعمه ولكن ليس هناك ارتباط
بين العمليات الارهابيه
وانخفاض طيب فيما يتعلق وضحت هذه النقطه
فيما يتعلق بسؤالي ما دلاله هذين الهجومين
الذين وقعا في في التزامن مع تحذير
السفاره الامريكيه الالمانيه وايضا تزامن
معهم تحذير شفوي من الداخليه المصريه و
وزاره الداخليه المصريه للكنائس بالغاء
رحلاتها الخارجيه وانشطتها الخارجيه ما
دلاله
ذلك الحقيقه الدلاله ان هناك حرب شرسه ما
زالت موجوده بين القوات الامنيه وزاره
الداخليه والقوات المسلحه والارهاب اللي
تسلل الى مصر عقب ثوره التخريب العربي
حداث الفوضى الامنيه ولكن لم يمضي سوى خمس
سنوات فقط من المواجهه اعاد الامن بقوه
ولكن الارهاب مازال متواجد يتناثر
ويتناولان في عمليات كضربات موجعه للارهاب
في الفتره الاخيره في ينا وايضا عمليات
ضبط لقيادات جماعيه ارهابيه وتبادل اطاق
نيران و ونهايه هؤلاء المجرمين اثر من
عمليه ت
انت ترى ان ردا على ردا على ما قامت به
الشرطه في الفتره الاخيره من اجراءات
تصاعديه يعني انت
تر استراتيجيه مكافحه الارهاب المصريه
ناجحه استراتيجيه مصر وضعه استراتيجيه
امنيه واستراتيجيه عامه لمواجهه وهل هي
ناجحه ام فاشله هذا هو سؤالي ناجحه لان
عقب ثوره التخريب العربي اذكرك في يناير
قالوا احنا مش اقل من فرنسا 50 سنه عبال
ما تتعدل وحولوا هجم الامن احنا بعد خمس
سنين يعود الامن بهذه القوه وينهي على
القيادات الارهابيه ويقوم بعمليات تنشيطيه
و ان
مض سي وضحت الفكره سيده نفين ملك المحاميه
النشطه الحقوقيه الكنائس المصريه اعلنت
انها تلقت تحذيرات شفويه من وزاره
الداخليه بالغاء كل رحلاتها وانشطتها
الخارجيه والبقاء داخل الكنائس لممارسه
العباده والانشطه داخل الكنائس ماذا يعني
هذا للمسيحيين في مصر هو تم التنبيه على
المسيحيين الاقباط من الكنيسه بتوقيف كل
الانشطه لمده ثلاث اسابيع و موضوع حتى
انهم يوقفوا الانشطه والرحلات الداخليه
ودي كانت بتبقى باب رزق كبير وباب يعني
للترفيه عن المواطنين يعني في النهايه وتم
غلقه اعتقد ان يعني من تداعيات هذه الامور
وهذا النجاح الامني الذي يتحدث عنه سعاده
اللواء اعتقد ان حتى الكنائس ودور العباده
هي مستهدفه في المرحله القادمه ما نحن
بصدده هو عنوان كبير جدا
للفشل في اداره الدوله الفشل في اداره
الصراع ليس فقط الفشل الامني ولكنه الفشل
في كافه المجالات الفشل الاقتصادي
والسياسي والعسكري والامني يعني هناك فشل
على كافه الاصعده وليس فقط الفشل الامني
كما تحدث هناك معلومات جاءت من السفاره
الالمانيه قبل هذا الحادث استهداف
السائحتين الالمانيتين التي لقي مصرعهما
اليوم للاسف قبلها ب 24 ساعه لماذا لم يتم
اتخاذ اجراءات استباقيه حتى بالتنبيه على
هؤلاء رعايا واتخاذ ما يجب من اجراءات وهل
هل يمكن اتخاذ فعلا اجراءات استباقيه في
مثل هذه الحالات هذا ما اريد ان اسال عنه
ايضا ضيفي
في في لندن الدكتور عمر عاشور استاذ
الدراسات الامنيه والعلوم السياسيه في
جامعه اكستر البريطانيه صحيح هنالك تحذير
من السفاره الالمانيه لا ندري ان كانت
السفاره الالمانيه قد شاركت معلوماتها لا
شك انها اصدرت التحذير بناء على معلومات
استخباراتيه هل اوصلت هذه المعلومات الى
الجهات المصريه ام لا لا ندري لانه سبق
وان حجبت معلومات عن مصر في تحقيقات
الطائره الروسيه على سبيل المثال لكن
لنفترض ان هذه المعلومات تمت مشاركتها مع
مصر هل هجوم كهجوم الغردقه شاب يسبح في في
البحر ويخرج الى السياح في فندق اخر
ويستخدم سكينا هل هذه هل هذا النوع من
الهجمات يمكن وقفه على سبيل
المثال الاجابه السريعه ع هذا النوع من
الهجمات يعني يسمى لو ليفل ريزم يعني
ارهاب منخفض المستوى ا الذي يحدثه هو
حقيقه ضعر ورعب اكثر منه اي شيء لا يحدث
ضرر ضخم او ضرر هائل كعمليه تفجير مثلا او
كالعمل التي شهدناها في في القاهره او في
لكن يحدث ضرر معنوي لكن ما يحدثه هو هو
يستهدف هدف حساس واستهدف هدف
ضعيف هذه يعني سيدات في البحر ف لا يوجد
اضعف من ذلك واكثر انحطاطا من ذلك ان
تهاجمهم وهم في البحر تهاجمهم بسكين ا لكن
ال الذي يحث هو انه يضرب قطاع حساس وقطع
اذا تكرر مثل هذا الهجوم يعني لانه كان
هنالك سابقه لهجوم ممث هذه هي نقطه هو هو
متكرر فعلا نعم هو متكرر يعني مايو 2016
حدث نفس الشيء تقريبا مايو العام الماضي
هجوم شخص او
شخصان قيل انهم تاثر بتنظيم الدوله وذهب
هب هناك حاول ان يذبح سائح تعاملت معهم
الشرطه قتلتهم احدهم كان يرتدي حزام ناسف
مزيف غير حقيقي وتعاملت معهم الشرطه
وانتهى الوضع هو التكرار هنا هذه هي
المشكله طيب الحدث جده هو الاكثر خطوره
تتعلق بالغردقه فماذا عن هجوم ابو صير
الذي تم فيه استهداف دوريه متحركه وليست
دوريه ثابته ومعنى استهداف دوريه متحركه
ان هؤلاء الذين تربصوا بهذه الدوريه كانت
لديهم معلومات عن خط سيرها ام ان هذا ليس
بالضروره
صحيحا لا لا هنا هذا صحيح هذا مستوى اخر
يعني هذا شخص يعني ترصد بدل جهد استخباري
ا لديه قدره على استخدام السلاح لديه قدره
على التخطيط لديه قدره على الهجوم
والانسحاب ا ولديه قدره على التعامل في
منطقه حساسه انت في المنطقه المركزيه يعني
في في قريب من القاهره ا فه مستوى اخر
يعني هو طبعا المستوى الاكثر اكثر تعقيدا
طبعا مستوى سيناء هذا يعني دخلنا في في
الجهد عسكري يعني استخدام مدفعيه متوسطه
المستوى صواريخ موجهه وهكذا مستوى ا يعني
اعلى بكثير الذي حدث خطوره ما يحدث سواء
كان في الغردقه او في في القاهره انه
متكرر يعني هذه منذ شهرين حدثت حادثه
مماثله في في القاهره قبلها طبعا الحديث
الشهيره في حلوان ا ف فهذه الحوادث متكرره
في مناطق حساسه اما في مناطق قريبه في
القاهره او حولها واما في مناطق بعيده عن
القاهره لكنها قطاع حساس جدا كقطاع
السياحه فهذه هي الخطوره الحقيقيه التي
نراها طيب اللواء مجدي شااهد في الواقع
هذه الحوادث متكرره انت تقول ان
الاستراتيجيه ناجحه اذا كانت الدوله لا
تستطيع حمايه المسيحيين وتقول لهم اقعدوا
في كنائس ولا تخرجوا ولا تستطيع حمايه
جنودها في سيناء ولا تستطيع حمايه
دورياتها في الوادي ولا تستطيع حمايه
السياح في البحر الاحمر اين هي الدوله اذا
في هذه الحاله
اي طبعا الضربات الاستباقيه اللي بيقولوا
عليها وتكرار الحوادث ا شفنا في اوروبا
تكرار حوادث ودهس دهس بسيارات يمكن تدكم
مش عمليات ارهابيه كبيره ومع ذلك اقوى
الاجهزه الامنيه في العالم لم تستطع انها
توقف الدهس المتكرر والذي نتج عنه وفيد
عداد كبيره يعني هنالك فارق بين تكرار
وتكرار يعني احنا نتحدث عن الاجهزه الكبرى
في العالم فنحن نتحدث عن هجوم كل عام كل
عامين انما نتحدث في مصر عن هجمات كل يوم
وبنفس الطريقه و ولا
تمنع المجرم يملك عنصرين انا ما املكش
اللي هو عنصر المفاجاه والمبادئ يقدر
يبتدي بالاعتداء ويقدر يفاجئ في اي وقت
طفل صغير اهوج او راجل مجنون اهوج يستطيع
انه يتعدى بالضرب على مارد ومع ذلك
المقبول ان ان يظل عنصر المفاجاه
والمباغتة
يبتدي بالضرب ان هو حقق نجاح ولكن الضربات
الاستباقيه اللي بتقوم بها الشرطه اذا كان
بيتم تهديد الكنايس فتم بالفعل ضبط اكبر
من خليه بضربات استباقيه نتج عنها ايقاف
تفجير في الكنائس وفي كثير من الكنائس لا
يعلن عل لان هذا امن قومي فهناك استباقيه
وهناك مواجهه حقيقيه لهؤلاء المجرمين
استاذه نفين ملك في العاده بعد مثل هذه
الهجمات يكون هنالك رد فعل يتمثل احيانا
في ضربات هنا وهناك تصفيات هنا وهناك
اعدامات هنا وهناك ما هو رد الفعل المتوقع
بعد هجومي الغردقه وابوصير بالجيزه وكما
اشرت انه دائما ما تتخذ هذه العمليات
والتي تنم عن الفشل في كافه المستويات كما
تحدثنا كذريعة
او لتنفيذ اعدامات بالجمله ا يعني شهدنا
هذا ومتكرر ايضا في كل حادثه انت اشرت ان
هذه الحوادث الان اصبحت شبه يوميه يشير ال
سياده اللواء يعني الى صناعه الخوف
والكراهيه في العالم كله والى تكرارها في
الغرب ولكن ما تشهده مصر من تكرار شبه
يومي او اسبوعي ا بعده يتم اتخاذ اجراءات
انتقاميه وتصفيه خارج نطاق القانون بدون
محاكمات لا نسمع عن تحقيقات نسمع فقط عن
تصفيه متهمين بدون اجراء اي تحقيقات ما
نشهده هنا ومغاير انه تم القبض على منفذ
العمليه الارهابيه في الغردقه ما نتمنى ان
يكون ان يتم تحقيق بشفافيه لم يتم تصفيه
هذا المتهم وتم القبض عليه حي نريد ان
تخرج لنا الاجهزه اجهزه التحقيقات بتحقيق
شفاف ينم عن اجراءات
حقيقيه لما بعد هذا العنصر ويعني كيف له
ان يتواصل مع العناصر الاخرى وما هي
الشبكه وراء هؤلاء نريد ان يتم تحقيق شفاف
للراي العام ولا يتم يعني دفن الحقائق كما
تم في قضيه جوليو روين روجيني وغيرها من
القضايا دكتور عمر عاشور هل هل الغرب
يعتقد ان مصر في الواقع في ظل هذه الظروف
تتبنى استراتيجيه صحيحه لمحاربه الارهاب
ام انه كما جاء في جلسه الكونجرس الامريكي
ام ان هذه الاستراتيجيه المتابعه من
الحكومه المصريه وهي استراتيجيه امنيه ولا
تفرق بين معتدل ومتطرف هي في الواقع ما
تؤدي الى خلق
الارهاب نعم الاجابه القصيره ايضا لا هم
يعني سواء الرسميين او الخبراء الغير
رسميين الاكاديميين وغيرهم تعتقدون انها
استراتيجيه
واحد غير فعاله اثنين غير اخلاقيه
ثلاثه نتيجتها واضحه واضحه للجميع الا
يعني بعض من يعني يردد بروباجندا لا اكثر
يعني ردد ما هو محفوظ ا المشكله هنا انا
يعني هي ثلاثه مستويات المستوى الاكبر
المستوى الكلي ساهمه السياسات والخطاب
الاعلامي و سياسات النظام الحالي في
القاهره في خلق بيئه هي هي بيئه استئصال
فبي استئصال هذه تدفع للتطرف يعني ا ربما
الشيء القانون الموجود في في دراسات
الامنيه رشن رادي كزيش لو قمعت تطرف الطرف
الاخر يعني وهذا هذا واضح في في الحاله
المصريه يعني من اعدامات وحملات القمع
وقتل خرق اطار القانون وغيره فهذا من
ناحيه هذا المستوى الاقل منه المستوى
المتوسط هو ان يعني تكتيكات المستخدمه
للمكافحه تكتيكات تزيد تزيد من خلق هذه
البيئه ا يعني في الحاله السيناويه كان
واضحه جدا يعني حين تستهدف طائرات اف 16
في مناطق تضرب بها في اماكن سكنيه او تضرب
مدفعيه ثقيله في في اماكن سكنيه لان جاءت
ك اخباريه عن تحرك مشتبه بهم في في هذه
المنطقه فيعني ما الذي ستفعله هو ردت فعل
السكان هناك على عليك
يعني فيوجد اجماع الى حد ما في الغرب ان
التكتيكات المستخدمه سواء على المستوى
المتوسط هذا او على المستوى الكلي انها
ليست فعاله
وستؤدي ماساء المشكله هنا هي ان المقترحات
او التوصيات ربما لا يؤخذ بها يعني بمنتهى
الصراحه يعني ا و وهناك يعني درس يعتقد ان
البعض انه تم استفاده منه في وقت مبارك هو
لو سمح بهامش حريات مره اخرى ف سيؤدي هذا
الى يناير اخرى وبالتالي يجب ضرب هذا
الهامش و وقمع وضرب بيد من حديد على اي
نوع من المعارضه سلميه او او عنيفه
وبالتالي يعني نضمن ان يحدث يناير مره
اخرى الدرس الذي استفاده البعض والذي
يتكرر الان شكرا جزيلا لك الدكتور عمر
عاشور استاذ الدراسات الامنيه والعلوم
السياسيه في جامعه اكستر البريطانيه واشكر
ايضا ضيفتي في الاستوديو نيفين ملك
المحاميه والنشطه الحقوقيه المصريه وضيفي
عبر الهاتف من القاهره اللواء مجدي الشاهد
مساعد وزير الداخليه المصري السابق